the hyperloop is the third thing elon
musk is famous for
following closely behind tesla and
spacex but the thing is
vacuum trains are a century-old idea
already and elon musk's idea the
air-cushion-based system the hockey
table in a vacuum tube
it's just not a viable solution and so
when elon musk made the idea open source
and then let all these private companies
start messing with it predictably all of
them abandoned the air cushion
technology
all of them now use maglev with that
it's safe to say that elon musk has
contributed absolutely
nothing to this project he just threw
the idea out there with great fanfare
made it open source and then let some
private companies do whatever the hell
they want
who then immediately broke away from the
air cushion tech because it was a bad
idea
and believe it or not this exact same
thing has already happened in the second
half of the 20th century
have you heard about the french iro
train it was this brand new
ultra-fast air-cushion-based train
because back then you were allowed to
call these things trains
which promised to revolutionize
transportation grandiose plans were made
working prototypes were built
and then fast forward a few years and no
one was talking about it
and why was that well because maglav
technology was gaining traction
and it promised to be much more
efficient than the air cushion tech now
this was in the 1970s
we don't see too many mega labs around
do we well first off it's expensive as
[ __ ]
and profitability is questionable at
best you know the
shanghai airport magolev perhaps the
most famous project
that thing just bleeds money namely
around 100 million dollars each year now
that's a lot
and the one thing that's even more
expensive is building the damn thing
in today's dollars the shanghai maglav
cost 56 million dollars per kilometer
in contrast high speed rail costs
between 17 and 21 million dollars per
kilometer this is in china of course
where the maglab is
meaning that if you build a maglev your
costs can be up to four times as much as
conventional high-speed rail
and then along comes elon musk and says
hey let's just put a vacuum chamber over
it and
it'll somehow be cheaper for example in
india the proposed chennai bengaluru
hyperloop line
was estimated at 20 million dollars per
kilometer including land purchases
eight million dollars cheaper than the
conventional high-speed rail which is
also being built there
now virgin hyperloop one in 2016 came
out with a more
sober estimate which is 134 to 193
million dollars per kilometer
now that being said conventional
high-speed rail can be incredibly
expensive as well the california
high-speed rail costs 164 million
dollars per kilometer
but here's the thing the project's
exorbitant price does not come from the
fact that it's a train
you know trains aren't these like future
age tech they have been built before and
they have been built for much cheaper
the causes for that exorbitant price are
external namely that you're trying to
build a
long continuous thing through california
through other people's lands and through
very densely built out areas
and also through some geologically
active terrain and this is something
that high speed rail and the hyperloop
have very much in common
but of course with the hyperloop comes
the additional challenge of putting a
vacuum tube over the rails
but hey the private sector's best minds
are working on this issue for almost a
decade now
so what have they accomplished in that
time so there are two companies doing
actual visible work on this
virgin hyperloop and hyperloop tt as in
transportation technologies
so first off virgin hyperlube they now
have a live test of a pod for
two people and oh my god who put these
panels together
there isn't a straight line there
there's like gigantic gaps all over
it's asymmetrical and of course these
panels are not you know structural
elements they're just decoration
but just optics wise this is kind of
terrible you know since building a
vacuum chamber involves putting together
pieces
very very very very precisely anyway it
doesn't exactly scream
professionalism or you know high-tech
precision and the other thing is
i highly suspect that this is just a
private jet fuselage cut up and put into
a futuristic tube
so i think that's the reason why the
windows are at their shoulders for some
reason
because this is indeed an airplane
fuselage and their seats are somewhat
raised above
where the airplane seats would normally
be but aside from
concerns over quality and the method of
construction
is this impressive should we be
impressed well
not after more than half a decade six
years
virgin hyperloop started in 2014 and
this test took place in november 2020
and so this test would have been
impressive in like early 2016
you know if they spent 2014 uh founding
the company and then 2015
working out the prototypes and then in
2016 we see a human test
like at that point i would have been
like halfway impressed but to do this
test at the end of 2020
i mean if they came out with some kind
of new technology of like
hey here's our new vacuum tunnel you
know 10 times cheaper to build and you
know
not prone to failure but instead they
were like hey check out our giant tic
tac
in a small vacuum tube with two people
in it this time
journalists have called it a
breakthrough but this is really just
like a half-assed proof of concept
really
and so let's look at the other company
hyperloop tt and see what they've been
up to
what is this a cgi image and the world's
first full-scale hyperloop isolation
valve
wow it only took them eight years so
why is progress on the hyperloop so
painfully slow
so glacial well that's because the
hyperloop is just
not a good concept because there's a
huge contradiction right in the middle
of it
namely that the hyperloop would only
make sense on long distances
but the one thing that would be
incredibly difficult to build
is long vacuum tubes whereas with
conventional rail or maglav even
distance is not really an issue only in
terms of costs maybe
so it doesn't really matter how far two
cities are from each other
building a train generally makes sense
because trains are very highly adaptable
to varying distances you know there's a
reason why austrian rail jets have a
maximum speed of 230 kilometers per hour
whereas the french tgfa goes by 320
kilometers per hour
different distances different speeds but
even if you have two points between
which the hyperloop speed is viable
you will still need to sell the idea to
the people who will be ultimately paying
for it
namely the taxpayers and so if you're a
decision maker
and propose a hyperloop connecting two
cities you will have a rather difficult
time
selling it to people you know everyone
likes shiny cgi
and everyone seems to be uncritically
accepting everything elon musk says
however when it comes to their money
people tend to be much more defensive
and conservative
and so during public discussions of the
hyperloop inconvenient questions might
surface
such as instead of building this nice
shiny high-end system which is not
compatible with everything else we have
why not just improve existing
infrastructure you know aunt julie has
trouble climbing up the tram every day
because it's a banged up high
floor thing from the 1950s and then it
chugs along into the city center at 20
kilometers per hour because the tracks
are busted
you know for her and tens of thousands
of other passengers a shiny new train
somewhere far away will not be much
consolation
and so if you have 1 billion dollars in
your budget let's say
and maglev would cost 1 billion
conventional rail
500 million and hyperloop 250 million in
a private company's opinion
which one would you build so just on the
face of it you could say
oh yeah of course we're gonna build a
hyperloop we're gonna save a bunch of
money and have this new high-tech
solution
but then some of your voters or
political opponents might do
some thinking for longer than five
seconds
and so they might ask hey how come just
maglav is four times as expensive as
maglev in a vacuum tube you know
shouldn't it be the other way around
does this company have any price
references from projects that actually
happened
no okay so is it a possibility that a
company proposes a price at the
beginning of a project and that that
price
starts climbing and climbing and
climbing reaching three to five times
the original estimate at the end
especially if the system only exists on
paper so far and cannot produce
any real life estimates so you do see
why a decision maker would have a really
hard time selling this to voters
and actually this is the reason why you
only see hyperloop projects in
developing
and or autocratic countries with young
or non-existent democracies
because there the people have little to
no control over how public money is
spent
so if you ever wondered why it's always
you know dictatorships that seem to be
jumping on these shiny new [ __ ]
projects
well that's why and so the engineering
problems together with the financial
problems and political problems
make the hyperloop a complete
non-starter and so i don't think we
should be taking the hyperloop any more
seriously than the french aero train
you know one or two hyperloops might get
built somewhere actually
most likely in autocratic regimes but
then it's going to be like the shanghai
maglev you know big fanfare huge
expectations but then people slowly
realized that
it's not that good actually you know
shanghai would have been better off with
like an
airport s-bahn or something which could
stop on the way and actually serve the
local community
instead of you know just whizzing past
neighborhoods and if they really wanted
to i mean for that kind of price they
could just build four tracks and have
the middle tracks act as the express
service and the outer tracks as the
stopping everywhere kind of service
but no the chinese government and
autocratic regime by the way
decided that the people of shanghai need
a maglev and so it was built
and it's pretty underwhelming it makes a
ton of losses and it doesn't serve the
community
you know unless you happen to be a
commuter between the city center and the
airport
and so i think this is the best case
scenario for the hyperloop
it's going to be this like ultra
exclusive ultra expensive
rich people transport between like a
convention center at an airport or
something
you know two shiny highly sanitized
locations where mortals don't usually go
and so i think it is time we stopped
taking the hyperloop seriously
because it is nothing new for the past
century we've been trying to come up
with this this one idea
the one idea that will whisk us into the
future on
the wings of [ __ ] science magic which
will just
wash away all our current bad outdated
old no good technology in a tidal wave
of innovation and genius
such was the promise of the aero train
the maglev and now the hyperloop
but all of them failed to bring about
the revolution because turns out in
terms of financing
politics and engineering conventional
rail is the best option
it is simple and just works
thank you for watching please consider
liking and subscribing
and i'll see you when i'll see you